to me how are you I'm well dan how you
doing I'm doing great
where are you right now I'm driving home
I just did four days in Bristol doing
the trade deadline so the pressures off
now I'm driving home and we'll start the
post deadline part of our program so is
there any ballpark you haven't been to
know I've been to all of them in fact
I've covered a game in 55 different
ballparks covers a game in 55 including
the old Metropolitan Stadium in
Minnesota and three and lanta ballpark
so yeah I keep kind of stuff like that
because I don't go anywhere else and I
don't do anything else so that's what I
have to collect our ballpark what's your
favorite pieces sports memorabilia you
have I don't I don't have anything Dan I
really don't I don't collect anything
but I did it's gonna sound terrible I
went to the White House for a luncheon
and I sat next to Stan Musial at the
luncheon and New Zealand Brooks Robinson
sat next to me how great is that so Stan
Musial says to me would you like an
autographed picture and even though I
don't collect anything because that's
not what I do of course I say yes I
would love one and two days later an
autographed picture of Stan Musial
showed up at my house and I went like
two years before I saw him again and the
first thing he said to me was did you
like the picture and I thought oh my
gosh and he's got so many other things
to worry about and to think about
remembered me being sent a picture and
thought enough of it two years later to
ask me about it that who Stan Musial was
one of the great all-time players and
along with Brooks Robinson the two nice
the superstar players I've ever met in
my life all right I have a stat of the
day I'm gonna I'm gonna bring you the
stat of the day Tim and I'm sure you're
gonna have something to add
to this when we do its eat and hit the
music for stat of the day
Brian Dozier was traded from the twins
to the Dodgers yesterday since the start
of the 2016 season
Dozier leads all second basemen in both
home runs 92 and RBIs 244 at your stat
of the day
[Music]
anything you would like to add to that
Tim I think I've got this right that
Dozier and Manny Machado have exactly
the same number of home runs over the
last four years I want to say and they
got traded to the same team and now
they're going to be playing shortstop at
second base next to each other and they
have the exact same number of homers and
I think though that total 143 is fourth
most among infielders in that time and
now those two will be playing together
and also Dozier is a Gold Glove winner
had a great second half of the season I
know we want we always focus on the
bigger names and Harper didn't get dealt
but you know sort of these secondary
trades those are the ones that in
September and even October that's when
they sort of surface where you go okay
that's why they got them but I'm curious
was there ever a framework for a trade
for Bryce Harper by any team my
understanding that never it never got to
that point now famously on Monday night
the Nationals just looked around to see
what was out there but I reported at the
time they were just seeing if they would
get overwhelmed at the last minute it
certainly did not happen so I don't
think a framework was ever in place that
yes we were gonna send Harper to the
Indians for a package like this and then
somebody backed out my understanding is
that never got that far but that's what
I'm curious about Tim because it felt
like a lot of these national insiders
including Buster Olney they felt like it
this is this is like a foregone
conclusion this is more likely than not
he was going to be dealt but how is it
that everybody thought he was gonna be
dealt but we didn't know what anybody
was offering to the Nationals well I
didn't think he was ever gonna be dealt
so I'm in a different camp there because
in in my research in my reporting I
never got anybody to tell me that yeah
there's something going on here
and I think reason people said it's
going to happen is because the Nationals
are in so much trouble the guy's free
agent at the end of the year so it makes
sense to get something for him now
rather than get a draft choice for him
say in November so I think that's why
but I never saw or heard any direct link
to a team with other names involved what
role we're talking to Tim Curtin from
ESPN what role does Scott Boras play in
Bryce Harper's staying or what's more
important to him that he stays where he
may want to or that he becomes the
highest-paid player in baseball and
maybe you can have both here but it
feels like that's what Scott boy you're
bringing in Scott Boras you're not
getting a hometown discount it feels
right now he does have a great
relationship Boras does with the
Nationals and vice versa and he has
Stephen Strasburg who told Scott Boras I
want to stay here I don't want to go out
on the free agent market and they signed
him to a long-term extension for an
enormous amount of money without
Strasburg ever getting to free agency I
do not see that happening with Bryce
Harper I think he's going to go out
there and look around
but God Boras will say what do you want
and Bryce will probably say I want to
see what's out there and that's why I
think there's a really good chance he's
going to leave the Nationals but I think
we still have to wait and see what
happens the last couple months here
before we're going to know who's
interested in him and is there any
chance he's going to stay in Washington
I I love asking this question I don't
know if there's a correct answer or a
bad answer but if I gave you a Harper
I'm gonna take trout out of this I gave
you mookie betts I gave you Harper and I
gave you Shohei Otani or somebody else
now I'm talking about young stars here
you got to give a max contract here who
are you going to invest in that's a
great question I would go with Harper
first bear
the mover mookie betts and barely over
manny machado and i will and when I say
barely if anyone picked the other two
there would be no argument here I still
just think then there's something about
this guy that is different than others
and I think his wildly competitive
nature which sometimes gets him in
trouble is still gonna lead to great
great things for him
I mean mookie betts ins defense and his
speed adds to the equation certainly but
I still think Harper is right there with
all the young players except for my
trout it was in a different category
than anybody else what other teams did
well prior to the trade deadline the Red
Sox did well Yankees did really well
Cubs did well getting Hamels the Dodgers
did well get Machado and Dozier and I
love what the Brewers did the Brewers
thinking out of the box said we can't
find a starting pitcher so we're just
going out slug everybody so they got
Mike Moustakas and Jonathan scopes
scopes a great defensive second baseman
on days he plays there but he'll play
some shortstop I also love with the
Diamondbacks did
Eduardo Escobar is really gonna help
them especially with Jake lamb being
hurt and those two relievers they got
yesterday Ziggler and dieckmann are
really going to fortify that bullpen and
you know Dan you win a knocked over with
a deep personal bullpen so there's so
many teams that did well and so few
teams that did poorly I think that just
shows you again what a great trading
deadline this was so many moves so many
interesting moves that lasted almost a
month but you talked about the bullpen
explain what the logic is of the Astros
obtaining the suspended pitcher Roberto
Osuna that that you take that PR hit for
the first couple of days but this is a
team that already won a World Series
like I understand like the Cubs brought
in or Aldous Chapman
they hadn't won a World Series the
Astros have won a World Series that's
why I was surprised that they brought in
Roberto Osuna who's been suspended for
domestic violence right yeah I'm with
you completely on this I was confused by
this move I'm uncomfortable with this
move I'm not sure I understand this move
now look they're the defending world
champs they've got every box checked
except for a late inning reliever and
they did a very controversial thing by
trading for someone who suspended for 75
games and that's huge baggage what he's
suspended for they're gonna have to
explain this to their fans they're gonna
have to explain it to their teammates
and I'm not sure how they're gonna do
that but we know how fandom works we
know how baseball works if that kid
comes in and it's great and believe me
his stuff is great
maybe all will be forgiven but I'll be
uncomfortable with that too because I'm
not sure you can easily forget at least
the charges that we think are happening
here and the reason why I singled it out
yesterday is obviously with domestic
violence you're trying to no you could
trade a guy who had been suspended
understand how a guy who suspended for
this is allowed to play in the
postseason where a guy suspended for
peds is not allowed to play in the
postseason I understand the incentive
for peds is not a good thing but I don't
understand the distinction between the
two I didn't even think of that I was
just curious because you can't trade a
player who's injured I don't think can
you so can you tree
you can trade a player who's been
suspended yeah you can trade a player
who is on suspension for a domestic
violate domestic policy violation and
that player is eligible for the
postseason during the year in which he
was suspended and again I'm confused by
that and I believe that's a rule that
baseball needs to look
into and ask is this the right thing we
should be doing here if you had to redo
your World Series pics would you well I
picked I think it was a long time ago
the Cubs to play the Astros I've changed
by my dad about 50 times since then
which of course is the ultimate beauty
of baseball whereas you never change
your basketball pick it's always Golden
State and Cleveland although obviously
not anymore so if I could change it I
would say the Red Sox are gonna play the
Dodgers in the World Series and I might
chase that again holiday because
baseball's does not is so great it does
not allow itself to be easily predicted
so I will see how the rest of the season
plays out it will be fascinating to
watch one other thing the inappropriate
tweet problem that baseball has how does
is baseball addressing this yes
apparently so that baseball is going to
make sure it's clubs and its players
know number one don't ever tweet
anything like that don't ever think like
that don't be stupid enough to do
anything like that and if you have then
get some sort of expert in to make sure
that is scrubbed away somehow I'm the
worst ever in technology I don't
understand how anything works beyond my
cell phone and I really think with that
also so I don't know how this works but
baseball has to understand in a 10 day
period when three good young players are
in the middle of this that the players
and the teams had better be more
diligent about educating players who a
never say or do those things and if you
have been that stupid find someone to
help you eradicate it somehow and
educate you about that safe travels Tim
great to catch up with you thank you
okay dad I'll pick up that's Tim
Kurkjian for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]